my next guest has just completed his
mission to be stung by the most
dangerous insects on the planet he's the
host of the hugely popular brave
wilderness channel on YouTube which
currently has over 650 million views for
clips such as this one here we go I'm
coyote Peterson and I'm about to enter
the sting zone with the tarantula hawk
one two
oh my gosh
please welcome Ellie Peterson
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now a coyote let's talk about that clip
don't touch him yeah in that clip you
are stung by the tarantula hawk and that
insect is said to have it's a type of
wasps that is said to have the second
most painful sting in the entire world
describe how that fell well in the
insect Kingdom in the insect Kingdom
okay so like a Taser going into my arm
immediate like is happening right and
all I could do is get that capsule on
top of the insect so it didn't get away
and sting my crew and then you know I'm
on the ground rolling around and what
you have to think about is present
present percent the audience wants to
know what is it that you're going
through right you got to collect
yourself and make it happen so why do
you do this
couldn't you ask someone who's been
stung and write down what they say right
yeah but if I got on YouTube and I did
that and just sat there and said guys
this is what happens when you get
somebody tranch lock people click off
right oh right right
the real goal is the education behind
all of this to show you what happens to
a human body if you take a sting and
that's gonna you know you guys you don't
think you ever and go out there actually
pick up on these tarantula Hawks right
no no we're not gonna business all what
I went through
so no saying I'm gonna check this animal
from a safe distance okay so you're in a
way you're doing this as a service for
all of us to show us what it's like so
that we don't go and find the most
painful insect in the world and then
force it to sting ourselves yes well
specifically you cuz I know that yeah
you might be out there in the desert
yeah yeah now you know well if the trick
is pretty well-established I don't go on
the side
[Applause]
you